et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
jean-baptiste lemoyne bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
secrétaire d'état chargé du tourisme des
français de l'étranger de la
francophonie en est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour quel style de chant du
groupe la dépêche merci d'être avec nous
christelle jean baptiste lemoyne vous
vous êtes ministre au quai d'orsay c'est
l'incertitude autour du sort de sophie
petrona la dernière otage française dans
le monde est ce que vous avez des
informations en est on ce matin est ce
qu elle a été libérée
celui sur ces sujets d'otages qui sont
éminemment sensible je ne donnerai
aucune information ce matin voilà
comprenait encore une fois ce sont des
affaires toujours très délicate et qu'il
convient et bien voilà de ne pas
commenter plus avec fait trop petit
moulin sur son ca vous savez on est
toujours très mobilisée au quai d'orsay
auprès de nos humanitaire certains
parfois ont été prises en otage certains
hélas ont perdu la vie je parle
d'humanitaire encore je pense au mois
d'août et à ces six jeunes de
l'organisation à ted mais toujours
toujours un rassemblement naturellement
nous sommes à leurs côtés au côté des
familles mais ce matin je ne peux pas
vous en dire plus on ne pouvait pas nous
en dire plus mais est-ce que son nous
dire est que les choses ont bougé au
moins ce que ça vous pouvez nous dire
c'est une évolution de la situation de
sophie pétrin je comprends que vous
essayez une troisième fois mais je
pourrais pas le plus loin ce matin allez
on va passer un autre sujet à la crise
sanitaire
creissels bertrand évidemment qui occupe
le devant de l'actualité un oui de
nombreuses questions sur la manière de
voir deux communiqués du gouvernement et
sur les mesures qui ont été prises
on sent une certaine une certaine
hésitation à la fois dans l'est dans les
discussions avec les autorités locales
et les représentants locaux et aussi
dans les annonces qui sont fait des
communiqués qui qui tombent assez tard
dimanche soir dans la
sur la situation à paris pour quelle
raison est ce qu'il ya c'est ce
changement de stratégie de la part de
matignon
moi je dirais que on apprend
progressivement de tout ce qui s'est
passé depuis loin de mars
souvenez vous au mois de mars c'est le
samedi pour le dimanche que par exemple
les restaurateurs ont appris qu'ils
allaient fermer
plus récemment nous avons pu au
contraire prendre le temps de travailler
avec les professionnels avec les
territoires et la semaine dernière avec
le premier ministre nous avions
rencontré les associations représentant
l'hôtellerie la restauration
nous avons pu travailler avec eux sur
des protocoles renforcer avant que des
mesures soient annoncées et donc je
crois que justement ce qui n'avait pas
été le cas à marseille par exemple à
marseille
nous avions pris déjà plus de
précautions qu'au mois de mars puisque
la décision n'est pas tombé d'un coup
d'un seul pour une fermeture du jour au
lendemain mais il ya eu plusieurs jours
pour permettre aux acteurs de
s'organiser
ne serait ce que pour pouvoir liquider
les stocks éviter que kiki gare de cela
donc je crois qu'avec jean castex
justement il ya cette méthode de travail
avec les territoires il a reçu justement
les mères d'un certain nombre de grandes
métropoles la semaine dernière grenoble
lille paris etc
et c'est d'ailleurs c'est la marque jean
castex ce travail et que les territoires
et ce travail avec les professionnels et
moi je le fais d'ailleurs de façon
hebdomadaire je réunis les pros celle du
tourisme hier soir et bruno le maire
encore nous étions avec eux pour
justement une audioconférence afin
d'être continuellement en retour
d'expérience du terrain comprennent par
exemple avoir fermé le restaurant à
marseille et par appareil est ce que
c'est
les discussions avec les professionnels
qui sont passées différemment je crois
que près ministre assume de dire il
fallait un moment être entendu des
français sur le fait que la situation
elle s'aggravait et il ya un moment il
faut aussi et bien voilà permettent par
des décisions fortes de faire prendre
conscience de cela regardez le taux de
remplissage d'un certain nombre de
services de réanimation par les patients
qu'aux vite donc je crois que
aujourd'hui cette prise de conscience
elle est là tout le monde se mobilise et
les professionnels au premier chef jeu
salué le professionnalisme
justement des restaurateurs qui ont
travaillé sur ces protocoles renforcer
désormais des tables et de six personnes
et non plus de 10 des cahiers de rappel
tout ça c'est des éléments qui vont nous
permettre de continuer à vivre tout en
combattant le virus voilà je pense que
c'est important que la vie soit plus
forte que le virus
on sait qu'on va devoir encore vivre
plusieurs mois dans cette situation là
et donc le fait de ne pas fermer
purement et simplement les activités et
bien participe de cette vitalité mais il
faut encadrer et réguler la façon dont
tu dont la vie s'organise alors il ya
quand même des dégâts économiques
notamment dans ce secteur de
l'hôtellerie restauration est ce que
vous arrivez à les chiffrer
ces dégâts économiques combien d'hôtels
combien de restaurants ont dû fermer
alors depuis le mois de mars on a mis
énormément dead en place pour pouvoir
aider les professionnels à passer ce cap
je rappelle le chômage partiel et les
exonérations de charges sur quatre mois
également l'éligibilité au fonds de
solidarité et surtout nous avons adapté
ses outils au fur et à mesure parce
qu'on a bien vu que après une parenthèse
estivale où l'été bleu blanc rouge que
j'avais appelé de mes voeux a bien
fonctionné hélas l'arrière saison
effectivement et moins au rendez vous et
donc on a adapté la semaine dernière ses
outils avec par exemple le prolongement
de l'activité partielle jusqu'à la fin
décembre 2010 2020
on a également augmenté le volet 1 du
fonds de solidarité il était de 1500
euros par mois il passe à dix mille
euros ça permet à des restaurateurs par
exemple est bien de prendre en charge un
certain nombre de charges fixes
une partie du loyer une partie des
peut-être de certaines redevances etc
donc on a été on est et on sera au
rendez vous dans la durée aux côtés des
professionnels parce que notre notre
souhait le plus cher c'est de préserver
les emplois
les talents les savoir faire pour
pouvoir rebondir le moment venu la durée
ça veut dire au delà de la fin de
l'année si jamais la situation continue
là on est sur des mesures qui vont
jusqu'au 31 décembre jean castex
cela dit il y aurait une clause de
revoyure en décembre il a dit voilà pour
l'instant pour lens jusqu'en décembre
et puis on évaluera au regard de la
situation ce qu'il conviendra de faire
ce qu elle isabelle borne également
redit hier dans notre eau dieu
conférence à est-ce que c'est suffisant
pour éviter les dégâts on a du mal à
croire malheureusement qu aucun hôtel qu
aucun restaurant tu vas être obligé de
fermer est ce que vous arrivez à
chiffrer voulait l'impact économique
écoutez effectivement on voit bien que
la situation est telle que hélas il y
aura sûrement ici et là des fermetures
est d'ores et déjà les professionnels
lui émis h le génie craignent que 20 à
25 % peut-être d'établissement soient en
grande fragilité
donc face à cela encore une fois on ne
mégote pas on déploie un soutien qui est
inédit
inédit c'est regarder dix milliards
d'euros de prêts garantis par l'état et
avec également des prêts qu'ils vont
pouvoir être remboursés sur une période
plus longue
c'est également avec l'activité
partielle plus la nationalisation des
salaires je crois que quand on regarde
ce qui était fait en france et qu'on
regarde ce qui était fait dans d'autres
pays
les prochaines du tourisme ils nous le
disent lorsqu'ils sont présents dans
plusieurs pays disent c'est très clair
c'est en france ont été les plus
protégés et les infrastructures les plus
touchés aujourd'hui on pense au grand
hôtel par exemple parisien quels sont
les secteurs de l'événementiel est un
secteur très touché
vous savez que un des moteurs du
tourisme c'est le tourisme d'affaires
les foires les congrès les salons sont
encore entravées
et il nous avons encore eu l'occasion de
travailler avec eux hier moi je souhaite
qu'on puisse avec bruno le maire
travailler aussi sur des protocoles qui
permette à cette filière peut-être de
reprendre des activités ne serait-ce que
ce qu'on appelle en be to be c'est à
dire pour tout ce qui est clientèle
d'affaires les salons grand public on
voit que il est peut-être encore comme
on dire des difficultés dans un premier
temps mais voilà les salons
professionnels les salons d'affaires les
séminaires c'est important qu'ils
puissent se tenir c'est important aussi
de reprendre c'est à dire que on ne
travaille pas seulement par
visioconférence et et en se voyant par
pixel interposés mais véritablement il
ya besoin de rencontres et surtout ce
sont des grands professionnels qui
savent gérer les flux les réguler de ce
point de vue là je veux saluer l'action
d'uni mail on va travailler avec eux
dans le dans les prochains justement
est-ce que vous avez des études sur la
propagation du virus en milieu fermé
on sait qu'il ya une étude dans un
restaurant un canton qui qui explique
que la climatisation fait circuler le
virus est ce que vous ayez des choses
qui ont été étudiées comme ça en france
alors justement comme vous dites jérôme
salomon le directeur général de la santé
fait état d'un certain nombre d'études
ou étude américaine également et c'est
pourquoi d'ailleurs à chaque fois nous
saisissons le conseil scientifique des
projets de protocole nous saisissons
pour recueillir son avis et moi je me
réjouis conseil scientifique justement
en tous les cas et valider ces
protocoles renfoncer renforcé pour les
restaurants qui permet aux françaises et
aux français de continuer à en profiter
et je leur dis voilà à vos fourchettes
rendez-vous dans les restaurants parce
que ils ont besoin d'être soutenus
quelque part c'est aussi c'est un acte
de plaisir mais c'est aussi un acte
citoyen n'y a eu aucune étude en france
sur les circuits les modes de
circulation du virus
écoutez life entre roger meece de la
santé au jura en charge de l'activité
économique du tourisme
mais ce que je peux vous dire c'est que
à chaque fois dans toutes les décisions
qu'on prend on les prend aussi en étant
éclairé par naturellement les avis
scientifiques par le conseil
scientifique c'est ce qui s'est passé
pour maintenir ouverts les restaurants
et on va parler du tourisme justement
avec un impact 1 on imagine
on est au bout nous dit l'arrière saison
est un petit peu plus difficile
on est au mois d'octobre est-ce que vous
avez un bilan de la saison estivale à
nos frères alors c'est une saison
estivale qui a été plutôt une bonne
surprise parce que les français ont été
massivement présents au rendez-vous pour
redécouvrir la france 94 % des français
qui sont partis en vacances sont restés
en france c'est 15 à 20 points de plus
que d'habitude et c'était très important
parce que on avait à côté de ça beaucoup
de clientèle internationale lointaines
comme les chinois comme les américains
qui n'ont pas pu venir donc c'est à
compenser alors que la partie intel fera
pas totalement mais en partie parce que
les français chaque été ils partent ils
sont 9 millions à partir ils dépensent
14 milliards d'euros
et bien là il ya une partie de cet
argent qui est du coup été dépensés dans
nos territoires et vous avez des
chiffres plus précis alors mais des
chiffres on a eu par exemple sur tous
les littoraux des taux d'occupation des
hôtels qui était le massif qui qui qui
était entre 90 % et 100 %
il ya eu un très grand succès des gîtes
de france 2 des destinations montagne
la montagne a fait le plein et c'est
d'ailleurs une bonne chose parce que
c'est un territoire par exemple sont des
territoires qui sont touchés par
réchauffement climatique qui ont besoin
de penser un tourisme des quatre saisons
de qui ont besoin de décès analysé
j'étais la semaine dernière au congrès
des domaines skiables de france à
grenoble et eux qui prennent à bras le
corps la transition énergétique le
transition climatique
eh bien ils vont travailler aussi sur le
des activités et l'été sur le fait de
proposer de nouvelles activités
donc on le voit le tourisme tricolore il
s'adapte il est très résilient mais il
ya eu un contraste aussi puisque des
territoires comme paris l'île de france
les grandes métropoles qui ont plutôt un
tourisme international ont été plus
touchés que d'autres et à l inverse
d'autres territoires littoraux le var
des pyrénées atlantiques ont connu de
très grand succès justement depuis
quelques jours certains ministres 17
crise comme vous venez de le dire ça va
être encore plusieurs mois peut-être une
année peut-être plus est ce que vous
êtes inquiet pour les vacances de noël
par exemple qui sont un moment une
saison touristique importante en france
où là on va peut-être où on n'est plus
confiné on va plus au restaurant en
intérêts
est-ce que vous avez inquiétudes sur
cette période de noël alors la période
de noël les professionnels ici prépare
soigneusement méticuleusement et là
aussi par exemple vacances noël souvent
ça rime aussi avec avec les sports
d'hiver avec la montagne
je peux vous dire que les professionnels
ils ont mis en place des protocoles et
vous pouvez regarder sur le site de
france montagne depuis le voyage en
train jusque au déplacement en
télécabine ou à la restauration tout est
fait pour qu'à tout moment et bien les
protocoles soient mises en place soit
respecté mais beaucoup repose aussi sur
la responsabilité individuelle des
français
les protocoles ils sont là encore
faut-il que chacun d'entre nous
s'astreignent également à leur respect
s'astreignent aux gestes les plus
élémentaires que maintenant on connaît
fameux gestes barrières parce que en
fait c'est individuellement et
collectivement qu'on arrivera à 20 que
ce virus est que eh bien voilà plus que
jamais la responsabilité de chacun elle
est là et parfois c'est vrai que c'est
surtout dans un cadre familial
on a envie de ces train de s'embrasser
etc on voit que c'est dans les fêtes
familiales dans les événements familiaux
souvent que et bien le virus se propage
donc il faut faire très attention être
prudent oui c'est vraiment la peine
comme christelle le rappeler cette crise
sanitaire et malheureusement amenée à
durer ce que vous travaillez avec les
élus avec les collectivités un nouveau
tourisme en france tout à fait il faut
avoir dans ce moment à la fois l'oeil
sur microscope voir ce qui ne va pas
dans le très court terme et comment on
peut aider au soutien et puis en même
temps avoir la longue-vue le tourisme de
demain c'est quoi et ce tourisme
tricolore comment il va rester sur le
podium
parce que je rappelle que nous sommes la
première destination touristique
mondiale
voilà en tout cas en entrant dans la
crise il faut pas que les cartes sont
rebattues à notre détriment
et donc le tourisme de demain je pense
qu'il aura une dimension encore toujours
plus durable on sent que le consommateur
il est prêt à ça le client le voyageur
il a des attentes
il souhaite que ce secteur du tourisme
il respecte également l'équilibré
l'harmonie
de cette planète qui est je pense qu'il
y aura aussi une plus grande répartition
des flux
on l'a vu dès cet été les comportements
et évoluer beaucoup de gens ont choisi
d'aller dans des territoires plus
reculer moins accessible parce que
finalement il voulait être un peu dans
une sorte de bulle de cocon ne pas être
au milieu d'une grande masse de
personnes donc je crois que c'est la
crise il sur tourisme dans certains
endroits on a beaucoup parlé de ce
problème notamment pour certaines
collectivités victime d'un sur tourisme
là vous travaillez une répartition sur
tout le territoire font alors je crois
que la crise finalement elle est au delà
d'être un révélateur
elle est un accélérateur effectivement
des évolutions sociologiques et de ce
point de vue là je pense qu'il ya une
marche qui était franchie on travaillait
déjà une meilleure répartition
géographique des flux mais je rappelle
que s'il ya quelques mois notre problème
comment dire nos réflexions ont porté
sur le sur tourisme aujourd'hui ont pâti
du sou tourisme et on voit bien aussi ce
que le sou tourisme génère en problème
pour des territoires qui sont parfois
hautement dépendant du tourisme
je sais que la corse est cher à votre
coeur nous avons d'ailleurs nous étions
que président la république en corse il
ya quelques semaines j'ai viré avec
premier ministre tout à fait heureux
pour le congrès de l'anem nous avons pu
travailler avec les avec les élus du
territoire et on a bien vu que si la
saison estivale a été réussi hélas elle
a sûrement été plus courte que prévue
qui va falloir dans la durée la aussi
aider les professionnels et bien à
passer ce cap
mais je crois que on le voit il ya
beaucoup de réflexions à l'oeuvre pour
un tourisme plus durable et aussi pour
que les acteurs du tourisme prennent
plus en compte la dimension digital
parce que on l'a vu le digital a envahi
nos vies et la crise a accéléré cela et
il faut que les acteurs du tourisme ne
voit pas la valeur ajoutée liés parfois
au digital pour les réservations et
c'est leur échapper donc on a demandé
d'ailleurs à olivier sichel qui est le
directeur général délégué de la caisse
des dépôts et consignations de plancher
sur ce sujet là on le fait au sein du
comité de filière tourisme aussi que
j'anime avec leur enquête le président
du welcome city lab donc je crois que
cette crise c'est aussi un moment pour
repenser le tourisme le tourisme
tricolore et essayer de prendre un temps
d'avancé
peut-être
vous êtes le mot krisis un engrais qu'il
a ce côté polysémique voilà des
opportunités peuvent aussi en être et
dans votre portefeuille jean-baptiste
lemoyne ya aussi les les français de
l'étranger et cette question qui se pose
des couples binationaux qui ne peuvent
pas se retrouver car certaines
frontières sont encore fermés qu'est ce
que vous allez faire pour eux alors on a
d'ores et déjà j on a mis en place une
procédure pour pouvoir rapprocher les
couples qui sont ni mariée ni pacsé et
je peux vous dire que il n'y a pas
beaucoup de pays dans le monde qui l'ont
fait donc la france doit être dans les
dix quinze pays qui ont mis en place une
procédure cette procédure
elle est désormais active elle
fonctionne il ya plus de 300 laissez
passer qui ont été délivrés depuis une
quinzaine de jours qui permettent à ces
coupes de se retrouver et donc il ya
encore plusieurs centaines de dossiers
qui sont en cours d'instruction je veux
rassurer tout c'est lover comme on le
dit ces amoureux en bon français parce
que je suis aussi sur internet à la
francophonie donc il faut pas que je me
laisse entraîner sur la pente de
l'utilisation de mots anglais mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que il ya
désormais de belles histoires qui me
sont rapportés des gens qui m'envoient
leurs photos de retrouvailles et je m'en
réjouis parce que c'est vrai que ce
virus à il n'aime pas l'amour nous aussi
donc je sais que ça a pris du temps les
gens ont parfois été séparés pendant
quatre cinq six mois et que leurs
attentes étaient fortes
j'espère désormais qu'avec cette
procédure
kono a mis en place dans cette situation
nous avons retrouvé nous avons à peu
près reçu 800 dossiers 300 ont reçu un
avis positif entre 50 et 100 ont dû
recevoir un avis négatif donc il doit en
rester encore quatre à cinq cents en
cours d'examen né des pays
particulièrement concernés plus que
d'autres
beaucoup de dossiers qui viennent des
états unis notamment
mais mais mais ça concerne un peu le
monde entier le premier le premier
laissez-passer concerne à quelqu'un qui
sait en amérique latine vous voyez donc
voilà c'est 4 à 500 ils vont avoir une
réponse quant à b ça n'arrête pas de
travailler dans les consulats au
ministère l'intérieur et donc les
réponses sont donnés chaque jour au fil
de l'eau
et tant que tant que le bouchon sera
l'art en un mot sur l'assemblée annuelle
des français de l'étranger crétal oui
vous venez d'être élu sénateur pour
quelle raison est ce que vous avez
décidé de ne pas siéger immédiatement au
sénat alors j'ai été très clair devant
les grands électeurs de l'yonne et je
les remercie de m'avoir fait confiance
avec marie evrard ma suppléante
c'est que j'étais candidat parce que
j'ai été sénateur de l'yonne
j'ai passionnément aimé ce mandat je me
suis investi et je crois pouvoir dire
qu'on a fait du bon travail avec les
élus et donc pour moi il était naturel
et bien aussi de me soumettre aux
suffrages des grands électeurs
et puis surtout c'est un moment très
particulier que nous vivons dans ce
temps c'est c'est un moment pas comme
les autres et donc ça sera un mandat pas
comme les autres
et justement je pense que je serai
d'autant plus utile au département de
l'yonne au commune de l'yonne en étant
toujours membre du gouvernement je me
suis beaucoup voir engagée pour que le
plan de relance il bénéficie pleinement
au département de l'yonne et je peux
vous dire que les rendez-vous avec soin
avec mes collègues ministres soit les
différentes administrations pour faire
avancer des dossiers
eh bien ils n'ont pas tardé on est à
l'oeuvre à l'action et donc c'est en
restant au gouvernement que je serai
utile et marie evrard qui était élu à
mes côtés siègera comme sénatrice de
l'yonne tout comme dominique verrien
également qui a été élu et bien voilà
nous serons finalement ils en ont deux
pour le prix d'un
c'est quand même quelques mois vous
étiez candidat pressenti pour être à la
mairie de biarritz a été compliqué de
venir faire campagne dans l'yonne en
tout cas les grands électeurs ils ont pu
juger voter et dire finalement on
souhaite pouvoir travailler avec lui et
et moi je n'ai jamais cessé d'oeuvrer
pour l'yonne vous savez y compris dans
cette période pré municipal que vous
évoquez toujours à tout moment quand un
élu de l'yonne se manifestait pour
porter un dossier j'étais présent au
rendez vous et on continuera comme ça et
vous allez continuer on imagine à
travailler pour les départementales et
pour les régionales dans votre
département dans votre région vous serez
candidat voit une de ces deux élections
à l'écouter c'est le temps de se
prononcer n'est pas venu mais je suis
conseiller départemental c'est un mandat
que j'exerce depuis 2008 exerce aussi
avec beaucoup de passion on a des gros
enjeu devant nous le fait qu' on puisse
tirer la fibre le très haut débit pour
nos administrés donc cédé potencier
plutôt candidats départementale écoutez
on verra le moment venu mais mais en
tous les cas pour l'instant je
m'investis pleinement dans ce mandat
avec des fines rémy qui est conseillère
départementale à mes côtés pour ce joli
canton du gatineau vous reconnaisse
comme edouard philippe vous êtes un peu
chargé de faire venir les élus de droite
dans le giron de la république en marche
vous savez je crois que beaucoup d'élus
enfin on n'a pas besoin de ça pas besoin
qu'on leur dise ce qu'il faut faire moi
ce que je constate c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup d'élus qui se reconnaissent
dans la démarche du président la
république qui est bien de réunir les
bonnes volontés les énergies d'où
qu'elles viennent
quand je regarde la table du conseil des
ministres où je vois des gens qui
viennent de la social démocratie avec
jean yves le drian
quand j'en vois d'autres qui viennent
justement plutôt du monde de l'écologie
etc
eh bien c'est ce qu'on retrouve dans nos
conseils municipaux on se retrouve
derrière un projet pour la commune et
berlin se retrouve derrière un projet
pour la france
et cette fédération des énergies mais je
trouve que voilà c'est cette france unie
dont on a besoin pour faire avancer le
pays surtout dans les moments je dirais
de de crise que nous connaissons et je
me réjouis que de nombreux élus à droite
continue à apporter un regard
bienveillant sur l'action du
gouvernement
on travaille très bien où je travaille
très bien par exemple avec les régions
de france avec président renaud muselier
et nous sommes issus de la même famille
politique à la base donc voilà fédérer
les énergies autour du vote sur les
néonicotinoïdes beaucoup d'abstention
beaucoup de quelques votes contre est-ce
que c'est pas révélateur quand même une
certaine fragilité de la majorité au
moins sur ces questions
environnementales
moi je me réjouie de ce vote en tous les
cas je peux vous dire que dans un
département où la betterave est
importante et on voit bien que il y
avait besoin d'utiliser encore c'est
néonicotinoïdes pour lutter contre cette
maladie de la jaunisse donc on le fait
on reste dans un cadre européen et
encore une fois on le fait avec toutes
les précautions d'usagé
maintenant ce sont des sujets sur
lesquels certains mettent un peu d'huile
sur le feu
je les ai vécu il ya quelques mois avec
l'accord avec le canada il est atteint
aubin on voit bien que sur les réseaux
sociaux fleurissent parfois beaucoup de
désinformation et qu' il est important
aussi sur ces sujets là qui peuvent être
très passionnel de raison garder et d'en
rester aux faits rien que les faits tous
les faits et merci beaucoup merci aux
mélomanes d'avoir été avec moi merci
cristal bertrand on passe ce titre au
club des territoires
[Musique]